[Music]
we're here in the Arthur M Sackler
Museum of the Harvard Art Museum's we're
here with dr. Robert Malory who's Alan J
Dworsky the curator of Chinese art has
been here at Harvard since 1986 one of
the ordinary features of Harvard's
Chinese collection are a series of
bronzes from the Song Dynasty perhaps
you could just say a few words about the
technology of making these bronzes sure
these bronzes are made using a very
complex method that was not used
anyplace else in the world most anytime
maybe until the 20th century maybe but
not before that called the piece mold
technique and the way they did it they
first made a model of the vessel in clay
which they fired to give it strength
durability and a very hard surface then
they would take small pieces of clay and
put them over sections of the vessel to
make the mold itself and that's why it's
called piece mold it's in numerous
different pieces after they have made
impressions from the model decoration
was carved into the model never forget
that one of the glories of these vessels
is that everything that you see on the
surface was integrally cast with the
vessel itself there is very little cold
working that is post casting chasing
chiseling and such it is integrally cast
so that that decoration for the most
part was incised engraved into the model
so that when you put the piece of clay
against the model and then pulled it off
it would have part of the shape of the
vessel and part of the decoration of
course those being clay and the bronze
when it's molting to go in is going to
be very hot means that the pieces have
to be fired this is a difficult part
because whenever you fire clay it's
going to shrink and so then you have to
have pieces that even though they have
shrunk and still fit together perfectly
and then you would bind them together
you have an inner mold otherwise they're
going to have a completely solid vessel
little pieces of bronze called chaplets
that hold the interior mold away from
the pieces of the outer mold when it's
all set you put the molten bronze in of
course the whole thing is upside down
the reason being it's upside down you
don't want any bubbles that are going to
be
bubbles in that molten bronze when they
rise to the top you want them on the
bottom of the legs where no one's going
to see them so it's a very complex
process but it gives superior casting
result thank you
you